Ladies and gentlemen, we come to the end of a very extensive back test over two
and a half years of data for one playbook for one model.
And basically, I'm going to be doing this live. So I'm going to be running
through the data and taking away kind of the key lessons, the important things,
things that I may want to look to improve, things that I want to completely
avoid and just overall, you know, just looking at everything.
All in all, what I will say is I'm extremely happy with this model, even as it
is right now. Right. So I'm also going to be taking notes on my candle. So
again, like I said, this is just raw life, me doing what I would do. But just
instead of, you know, doing it on my own.
I'm just doing it basically on record. Right. So do bear with me if I'm writing
or something like that. But I want to walk you through kind of this entire
process.
Again, just documentation as opposed to creation. So I'm looking at, you know,
really the main kind of takeaway lessons.
So let's start off. So I'm not sure what that is as a percentage in total
without kind of butchering it. So what I want to do first and foremost is I
want to just find out what the percentage is.
So also, actually, what I should let you know is I had to redo the entirety of
2024.
If you remember in 2024, I was risking 1% of current balance. So I was comp
ounding. The problem, however, with that is that it makes the data accurate.
For example, what you'll find is that one specific setup, right, may only have,
you know, on the lower end of the scale, may only have, you know, 12, 15 trades
for that specific setup.
So it's a rare occurrence setup. And some are a lot more frequent.
But the problem is is when you're not doing initial balance, so 1% of 1 million
every single time, that can heavily get skewed.
Because if, for example, you took, you know, five of those trades in 2024, at
the end of 2024, back to back, for example, and you're risking 1% of current
balance and you're already a 100%.
And you're basically risking 2% of start imbalance on that setup. And so that
can heavily skew the data. And that was something I was aware of.
And again, instead of being lazy, I was proactive and decided that it's the
best thing and the right thing to do for the data to go and risk adjust that
setup.
So what you can see here is if we select all the sessions, right, if we go all
sessions, you'll see that it's obviously the return is drastically higher.
Right, profit factor actually lowers a little bit. But you can see the Zella
score is extremely high.
You know, and it ends up being 3.5 million. That's because 2024 is also done.
So you'll see here, I have 2023, 2024, and then 2024 risk adjusted.
So I adjusted risk and went and took every single trade again.
What I noticed whilst I did it again every single time is that there were
actually a couple of trades that were a little bit, you know, maybe shouldn't
have taken.
Or a couple of trades that I didn't take that should have taken right so it
ends up doing the difference ends up being.
If we compare them kind of both.
So 2024 when I in fact let's go into let's start with this one. So it would
have been 137% return right 108 trades taken and 137% return.
A 35% win rate and a 2.78 profit factor. That's on that's on risk in current
balance, right?
You can see the equity curve is still decent, very, very positive equity curve.
But now if we look at, for example, risk adjusted, right?
You can see we actually have a 3.09 profit factor. So we have a higher profit
factor.
The trade win rate is 34.9%. We end up taking 107 trades. So one trade less.
We still have a really high zealous score, a higher profit factor.
And yeah, still a very healthy equity curve.
But I decided to go back and risk adjust. So instead of 137%, it actually is 94
%, which is the accurate return, risking 1% per trade.
Of course, you can compound your account.
But the reality is is that most of you are probably going to trade prop firms
and you're probably going to take 1% of your current balance and you're going
to take payouts and reset the account and go again.
And so, you know, we just want to get the data of the edge.
When it comes to whether you're going to compound accounts, whether you're
going to risk incrementally, that is on you.
But obviously you can see that risking incrementally and risking on current
balance and compounding the account obviously is more profitable because you
get to a point where you're risking more.
And the reality is, if I would have risked 2% per trade, if I don't 1% per
trade, this would be double.
So, of course, the problem is, is that there are all down periods, right?
So that's something we have to be obviously aware of.
So to be clear, I went and did everything with a 1% fixed risk.
So that is why you're kind of seeing that.
So if we go in here now and we look at everything risk adjusted, we can see
again, I just want to make sure.
So we have.
I started with $1 million.
My net P and L was $2,168,636.43.
What is the percentage return?
So it's actually a 216.86% return over two and a half years.
So 216.8% over 2.5 years, meaning that's an average of 86% return per year.
And then adjusted for the amount of months that we traded, which was 10.
That's an average of 8.6% return each month, right?
So 8.6 are average per month.
Very, very good.
So that's what we can say.
So we understand that we had a 216% return.
Which is average at around 8.6% a month.
Really good numbers.
A 3.07 profit factor.
Very good.
That's very good.
We have a 33% win rate.
Which is also really good considering the fact that our average win to lose in
trade is a 6.23.
So that means for every $1 that we lose when we lose, we return $6 when we win.
So 6.23.
That's great.
So you can see that our average loss is lower than 1% because of management.
And that average win is over 5% because of management.
So you can see that management as a principal really, really works well.
So now what we can do, we're going to a little bit deeper on our data, right?
So we'll go to reports.
Now also Zella have made an update.
So the reports have changed as the first time I'm seeing it myself.
So let's just go in as I usually would, right?
So let's take a little look at overview here.
What we can see is our best month was April of 2024, returning almost 25% in a
single month.
The lowest month was June of 2073, where we had a drawdown period of 3.7%.
Our average is, you know, 9% per month.
Really, really nice.
So you can see here we have a total of 230 trades.
That's an adequate amount of data.
It's an adequate sample size to prove that we have an edge.
We can see we won 62 trades.
We lose 126 trades and we break even on 42 of those trades.
Our max consecutive wins are 4.
Our max consecutive losses are 7.
So again, that drawdown period.
No comms, no fees, no swap.
Our largest profit on any one given trade was 9.4%.
And our largest loss ended up being 1.5, 1.05 somehow.
Our average hold time is around 4 hours.
Average hold time for winning trades is around 12 hours.
Our average hold time for losing trades is around 39 minutes.
And our average hold time in square trades is 3 hours.
Our average trade, P and L is 4,000.
Our profit factor is 4.
Um, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb.
Largest profitable day.
Largest profitable day was 11%.
Largest losing day is 3% of the day.
Average planned our multiple is 41.
Average realized our multiple is 12.
That is inaccurate.
Our multiple for some reason is, I don't know, just doesn't.
Um, I don't know, it doesn't really go well.
For some reason, I don't actually recall what it is, but it's fine.
Um, again, I'm not really sure if that's accurate,
but max drawdown is 6%.
Um, average drawdown is 2%.
Cool.
Really healthy equity curve.
That's exactly what you want to see, right?
The problem is when you have an edge that's up and then it's down for drawdown
periods
for a longer accelerated time, this is like really just a very, very, very good
equity curve.
Okay, look how deep it into returns, so what I've noticed is that they've
actually, um, changed,
so you could have had setups here before, but now you have to go to tags.
And you look at each tag individually.
So what I'm really most interested in is the setups, right?
So let's take a look in general here.
You can see here, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
So what we can see here is the overall out of all the setups we have,
there was only one setup that doesn't work and it's practically breaking.
I mean, 0.6% loss overall, which means quite frankly, we don't need to trade
that setup.
So that would be the New York sweep Asia.
So only losing setup is when New York sweeps Asia.
But what we can also note is that with this setup, we have a 23% win rate, so
apparently it's profitable.
How does it have a positive profit factor then?
No, no, no, that's New York sweep London.
We're not looking at you, New York sweep London.
I don't know why that's.
Okay, let's go back.
Okay, New York sweep Asia.
Thank you.
So what we can see here is that we took three trades with this setup.
So in two and a half years, only three trades met the criteria of a New York
sweep.
It's two in and of itself, but this setup basically doesn't really show up
anyway.
So three trades taken in 2.5 years.
That's fine.
Let's see what else we've got.
So what's our most profitable?
Our most profitable is New York sweep Lull and discretion.
Now, here's what you should understand that with discretion, great profit
factor, great win rate on discretion.
Now, discretion actually isn't something where discretion isn't something that
is actually like fully discretionary.
It's principled.
So the only two discretionary factors there are is number one.
When the M1 is bearish and the M15 is bearish, but the M1 is extremely large.
So that could be a large news event or it could be a small trading range.
So for example, the M1 is the same as M15.
Instead, instead of using the external market structure for the M1, we just go
to internal and we trade based off of the internal.
So that is obviously something that can be done.
So now what I can do is I can make that a principle.
But you'll notice that every discretionary trade also has another setup within
it.
You can see, for example, this is a New York sweep Lull, that's discretion.
This is a Frankfurt sweep continuation.
So that will also count as those.
That just tells me two things.
Number one, both discretionary principles.
The first is that the obviously M1 internal.
The second is M15 discretion.
And that M15 discretion was only used a couple of times.
Now, unfortunately, I will have to go through every one of these trades to find
out which was what.
You can see here, we only take nine, 16, 25.
So we take 25 trades with this.
So it's not huge.
It's around about 11%.
So 11% of all of our trades were discretion.
But that discretion is simply just even M1 internal, which isn't discretion at
all, or M15 market structure.
Now that can be discretionary.
However, the M15 structure, I think there's like three or four trades that are
part of the M15.
And what that principle is, is basically just not using, for example, like Asia
session, Asia session, Asia's high or Asia low as a swing point, especially in
a confined range.
So, for example, let's have a look.
So here we are.
So, for example, let's say, you know, let's use this.
So let's say, for example, price is trading lower like this.
And then let's say there's a little bit of a pullback the next day.
And then price is lower like this.
And let's say Asia session highs here.
And then price shifts above these highs like this and technically on the M15 is
a change of character.
Then it shifts on the one minute, and then we trade lower like this.
That for me is fine.
I don't need to consider that as a change of character, because for me, this
kind of this pullback here on Asia session high is irrelevant.
I see that as liquidity.
So that is when you'll see me, you'll see in the back test and go and find them
yourself.
You'll see me use discretion for the M15.
And I think I use that on roughly like four trades, five is maximum.
So, yeah.
Okay.
So we have these two tags and the tags are discretion.
And yeah, actually just discretion.
So you can see here that.
Okay.
Is this also included in discretion?
Yeah.
So this is also included in discretion.
So you can see here that the least performing tag is Frankfurt sweep
continuation.
I'm pretty sure that when Frankfurt and again, it's only two trades, very small
sample size.
We lose 1.5% and we only take two trades.
So when I use the internal structure or the M15 don't apply for the Frankfurt
sweep continuation.
There's a minus 1.5% return and it's only two trades.
So it's not, it's not really something that I have to care about avoiding or
trying to work on again.
But when it comes to testing your goal isn't to try to refine every single
piece of data.
It's a look for the big, clear, obvious, you know, yeah, the big, clear and
obvious things
that you can work on to make your training better.
So, yeah.
Again, discretion being one of the most profitable, but all discretion is using
the M1 internal,
which say something.
So what we can see here is we know that the least performing tag is New York
sweep.
We can see here that our highest win rate trade.
So New York continuation from London has 19 trades with a 63% win rate.
So by, we can already see that that is our, that's an A plus set up, right?
That's how it becomes categorized.
That's an A plus set up.
So this is filtration based off of win rate.
So you can see here that the New York continuation from London, which we've
already gone over,
but that's essentially where, you know, let's say, for example, two scenarios.
So scenario number one is we are trending lower, right?
And then London's going to open here, right?
So then London, London opens and we have a break of structure with London.
And then New York comes back up into the point of interest, kind of created
between even London or the law.
And then trading out of that area in that direction.
The second scenario, which I think I took like one trade with this.
And I flagged it for review is the, essentially when we're bearish, for example
, right?
So we're obviously bearish like this.
And prices in here, right?
And we've, you know, we're in a very important area of interest.
Price London sweeps the highest, for example, and then start trading away.
Now we don't necessarily break structure, but we're in a really interested area
of price.
And then New York opens from like here and then trading this, right?
Again, that happened like once or twice, but that was a great setup.
So New York continuation from London, 20 trades in total.
We know that when that setup comes around, which it doesn't come around often,
right?
It comes up maybe, I don't know, what is that?
We're like a little bit less than once a month. So we'll get this set up, you
know, on average, maybe once a month.
But we know that when that, that's set up because that's an A plus set up.
And what you do with that information is completely on you.
But that's just what the data is telling us.
We also see that over a 50% win rate comes from the New York sweep of law,
right?
So when New York sweeps the kind of price, and that's probably something to do
with the kind of mean reversion.
So when price is trading in the same direction, for example, bearish.
And then London is in here and then London finishes and New York begins here.
In this period, there's a law, right? And then New York opens and New York
sweeps that law and then trades.
That set up has a 55% win rate.
And the reality is that that's probably based somewhat of mean reversion.
Because if New York sweeps law, that very much likely means that law swept
London and New York sweeps law.
So we are much higher in the price like, meaning there's a higher probability
of at least a mean reversion.
So an expansion out back into at least, you know, kind of like a 50% retr
acement, right?
That's the standard deviation from expansion and then continuation.
So at least this phase of price here, which is why it has a high win rate.
Doesn't necessarily mean that it's the most profitable it could be, but not
necessarily.
So, yeah.
It's what else we've got.
So let's look at our setups then.
Okay.
So what was the most traded?
So the most traded was London sweep of Frankfurt, but it only has a 28% win
rate.
And it's the highest traded.
So 85 trades, right?
Okay. Average win to loss is good.
85 trades.
That's a large book of our trades and 40% of the 216% come from that.
So that is our kind of most that's our highest occurring setup.
So now that I know that, for example, let's see.
So London, London sweep, Frank.
Right.
Highest occurring.
85 trades.
That has a 26% win rate.
Which again is electrically profitable because it has an average of over.
It has a 5.5 times average win to lose in trade.
So that is a setup and again, 39% return.
So 39% profit.
So that's something that I'm going to want to optimize because I believe that I
can probably optimize the win rate.
Right?
Yeah, I believe I can probably optimize the win rate of that system.
That means I may take fewer trades, but it's going to be more profitable.
That's another thing as well.
Sometimes, you know, if I optimize the win rate, it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's going to be more profitable.
Because if I optimize the win rate, but in the process of doing so, I also wipe
out a lot of winning trades, then, you know, it also may not be profitable as
profitable.
So it doesn't, just because it's a low win rate, doesn't mean that you're going
to make it more profitable with a higher win rate.
Could mean a lot fewer trades.
For example, but I still believe that I can increase both the win rate and the
overall return.
So that's something that I basically want to focus on.
One set up that I definitely want to optimize is London sweep rank.
So then I want to basically go deeper into the data of that.
We have again, London sweep Asia.
That returned 51%.
So that's again, close to being our, it's our second most frequent.
So these two, these two setups between them, make up over half of all of the
trades taken in a two year period.
Right.
And now the good thing is, is that they are obviously very profitable, which is
a good thing.
Oh, wait, I didn't see this one. That's our most profitable.
76% comes from that set up with only 19 trades.
So that's the trade that you look at, and you're like, that's my a plus set up.
If that set up occurs.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, guys.
I'm reading data.
That is irrelevant.
I'm going to have to go back now, because that isn't necessarily.
Accurate. Okay.
Very important. You select your data, right?
I'm actually going to remove that 2024.
I only have it there because I wanted to show you it.
So sessions.
2024.
I don't need this.
Can I.
Can I archive it?
No problem.
Cool. That's gone. That one is filled with my data now.
Okay. Let's show that again.
So I need to grab that off because that's not necessarily correct.
But was everything else correct?
I'm sorry, subs discretion.
40%. Yeah.
40.
Okay. Good. Everything is now accurate.
Cool. Let's look at that again, then shall we?
So again, still the same thing.
Actually, a little bit of higher percentage win rate.
Pretty much averages itself.
Actually, 26% 60 trades.
So not 85.
So 60 trades.
30 30.
30.8% return or 30.85.
So we'll call it 31% return.
So what 31% return?
60 trades with a 26% win rate.
Okay.
Again, that still has a, what is that as a mobile player?
As a multiplier, that is what we can do is we can go to dashboard, go to filter
.
We can go to tags.
We can go to setups.
And it was London sweep Frank.
Yeah.
Cool. So this is the data for that, that system.
You see, we have a 5.85 times more player.
So that's solid.
So that's obviously still definitely one that we want to look at because it's
our most highest frequently occurring setup.
So we're going to take this trade the most.
So it makes sense to try to optimize that the most.
Right.
Let's see what else we have to remove this for now.
Again, there's so much that you can do with this data as long as you know how
to look at it properly.
And honestly, like what I'm doing in this video, I'm probably going to end up
going away and doing more data synopsis.
But again, we're going to be just looking at the most important ones for now.
Let's see what else. So we have London sweep Asia.
And just before we move on, we want to increase win rate.
Of the London sweep Frank. And just so you know, the way that I'm going to do
that is basically.
If we come in here, right, I'm going to go to compare.
What we're going to do here is obviously your dollar, and we're going to do.
It is London sweep Frank.
So London sweep Frank.
All sides all be now start date.
First affair until, you know, here, I'm going to your dollar tags.
London.
London sweep Frank.
Side all sides trade P and L all.
Start date.
2023 fair, but the beginning and then up until pretty much present day.
Okay. Now we can look at other tags as well.
So for example, London sweep Frank is just one thing.
But what happens when we have, let's say, for example, London sweep Frank comes
from a.
A strong point of interest versus when it comes from a.
Weak points of interest, and I can generate that report.
And now it's going to tell me the following.
So what we can see here is the.
So we can see here is that when we use a strong point of interest, the win rate
increases to 33%.
When we use a weak point of interest, the win rate is 29%, which means that
they're both still profitable.
But the reality is, is that one of these setups is obviously better.
Like objectively speaking, most likely.
Total P and L 100% total P and L 58%.
So still very much profitable.
So that doesn't really give us much of a difference.
But then what you can do is you can go, okay, well, that was weak.
What about if it's weak and then the phase of the trend, for example, or if
there was news or if there was no news, right?
You can start playing around with your tags and starting to understand.
Okay.
Well, the setup itself is London sweeps Frank, but then what are the variables?
Well, what phase of price will be in?
Will we trending?
Have we just had a change of character?
Right?
Was there any levels of discretion used?
So that's another thing we can do as well is we can look at remove weak and
remove strong for now.
And then let's also add in discretion.
So what happens when we use discretion versus non discretion?
So we can see here that the discretionary ones and again, the discretion ones
are really just about.
Okay, that's also a factor in that.
So discretion is helpful as well.
How about when we go, for example, to empty leg versus broad.
To leg versus broad.
So you can see here that the empty, the broad point of interest is again more
profitable than the empty leg point of interest, but still both very profitable
.
So there's not really much that we can do there.
That's what I mean.
But if we removed this, right, we could remove this and it would increase our
win rate.
If we didn't take anything that was in this scenario, we could increase the win
rate, but we'd also cut off 55 set return.
So it's a very important thing to understand that the win rate alone is
meaningless.
Right.
The win rate alone is literally meaningless.
It's going to be difficult to look at refinements that we can make for this
specific set up.
I still do think that I can find things if I dig deeper.
I don't know whether these.
I have to edit these.
I'm not sure.
Yes, well.
168 trades matched.
Yeah, this is inaccurate.
I don't know whether this is the right yes or not.
Okay.
I need to look deeper into how to compare properly because at the moment.
I can do it based off of obviously setups, for example, so London.
That's still inaccurate.
85, 33.
Could be New York.
So we can see there, for example, one thing we obviously can look at that is
objectively and the data reads properly.
It doesn't have a thing as well.
It's important to be able to understand how to speak to the data and how to
have the data speak to you.
Another thing you can do as well, which I'm not doing right now, but I will
when I'm alone, is using AI using chat sheet to help you with your data.
Massively important, but again, that's that's something that you'll have to do
yourself.
But what we can see is New York and London.
This is a differentiation.
So New York has a higher win rate than London.
London has a lower win rate.
New York is more profitable.
They are both relatively equal in terms of what they overall return, but for
New York setups, you get less, less frequency, but higher quality.
So you can see that 105% is returned in New York and 93% is returned in London.
Now, that means there's probably some trades that aren't tagged, because that's
another thing that has to do as well.
In 2024, I realized that was actually some trades not tagged.
So I'll have to also go and find out which trades aren't tagged.
Let's go to tags.
That's for you.
Okay.
New York continuation from London, because we're reading the data incredibly.
Okay, the data was on 2024, not risk adjusted as well.
So just to be clear, this is the accurate data.
Now that we've removed that.
So we can see that the actual most profitable, I believe.
Yeah, the actual most profitable setup is the London sweep Asia.
It's also the most traded.
A three profit factor and a 30% win rate and a 6.8.
Average win to lose an average winter loss ratio, which is insane.
We can look at these other things as well, and we can look at point of interest
.
So what we can see is remove this and go only.
You can see again, every single point of interest, every single type of point
of interest is profitable, but strong points of interest.
Are number one, a much higher win rate.
So when you have a strong point of interest, again, this is where you can start
differentiating a plus b plus.
For example, you know that if I tag if I have a.
If I have a, in fact, let's do it right now and see if this will tell us if the
accurate, if the data is reading accurate.
So let's say we have.
London sweep Asia.
London sweep Asia, because the logic on this should be if both are tagged, then
yes.
So London sweep Asia from.
Strong and London sweep Asia from.
Week, broad or empty leg, if it gives me every single trade as a part of the
empty leg, then it's a big problem.
It's not the day is not really properly, which is the other thing.
I know that I will be able to go and get the accurate data on.
From chat, because right now, again, it's very important how your data
communicates to you.
So, for example, we have right here is 115 trades that have matched, but there
aren't 115 trades that were both London sweep Asia and strong point of interest
.
So the logic isn't correct, in my opinion, on how the tags should be run.
So what I'm better off doing is input in the data into chat GPT and letting
chat GPT communicate with me on the data.
Because, for example, I will be able to know by going into dashboard and
filtering off of tags and doing setups.
Set up London sweep Asia.
And point of interest.
Strong.
So this is should take both of them together.
So you can see here.
For London sweep Asia.
From a strong point of interest.
It has a 50% win rate.
So, when the model is like this, which again, I already had my intonations and
said that this is an A plus out, but now the data confirms that prices bearish.
Asia session is in here.
We have a strong point of interest up here, which is a point of interest
responsible for breaking structure.
London sweeps Asia into this point of interest, lower timeframe shift, entry in
here.
Five are down here, boom, boom, boom, boom. That has a 50 over a 50% win rate.
Right. So it has over, it has over a 50% win rate.
It has a total of 20 trades taken. So on average, once a month, you'll get a
London sweeps Asia into a strong point of interest.
Right.
Pretty sure these are all the old trades taken.
Right. And now if you look at, for example, London sweep interest London.
And then you look at, let's say, week, for example, right.
That has a 25% win rate.
So you can see we have six, 10, 12 trades in total.
And again, still a 9% return.
So it still makes sense to trade it. It's a very profitable model.
And with good management, this has a nine times multiplier.
So again, there's not really anything you can do. Like, yes, the drawdown is an
ideal on it, which is why you manage risk appropriately.
The win rate of that is not great, but the profitability is there.
Right. It returns 9%. So if you take that set up every time it returns over a
long enough period of time, you will make money.
Right.
But you can see that it's half in terms of win rate.
So if you look at that week, and then you look at it with a strong, for example
, return 9%, with a strong turn 43%, a six profit factor.
A 5.5 win rate. So you know, that is without a shadow of a doubt, an A plus set
up.
And then again, you can just note these things down, right.
And you go through everything and you decode all the data and you know, okay,
here are my A plus cells.
Right.
And then you start understanding.
And again, depends on how you're going to manage it, but for me personally, I
can block.
I have, I have a 4% buffer on my friend and account.
And my A plus set up is now showing itself.
Well, maybe instead of risking, you know, my standard is 0.5% or 1%, maybe I
risk 1.5% or 2%.
Right. That's dynamic, dynamic scaling of risk because you understand the setup
that you're dealing with.
Right. Very important thing.
And doubling down on what you know works and works well.
Again, if we go back into dashboard.
Because all part of the same playbook, the playbook itself is m15 pro trend.
Right.
Wait for a sweep of some type of liquidity or trade from a strong point of
interest.
Lower timeframe shift trade.
That's the, that's the strategy.
But the strategy can be compressed down into different types of setups that
occur inside of that strategy.
And then that's how you can differentiate whether it's an A plus set up or not.
Because there's a difference between a playbook and a setup.
You can have a variation of a trade that meets all the same criteria as another
trade.
But they are different trades and they return differently.
They behave differently.
Right.
So again, honestly, after governing enough data, what we have found is that
there isn't a single variation bar.
The bar, the.
There's an a single variation.
Bar the New York sweep in Asia.
That is unprofitable.
But I'm still going to play with this data deeper.
But it may end up being that I don't necessarily change anything.
Maybe I change how I approach certain things.
Right.
Maybe I change how I risk on each setup.
Those are some other things.
There's a couple of other things as well.
Like, for example, flag for review.
Right.
You can see here that there are, you know, 29 trades that I flagged that I want
to go in and look at.
And they may have their different reasons.
Because although there are many profitable trades in here, there are some that
if I go in here, for example, it's only a 30% win rate.
If I go in here, I might be able to start understanding something.
For example, there was one thing that I, I know that I kept on seeing from a
specific setup.
That was, I don't know why it's so bright green.
It's unreadable, but.
There was New York.
Low sweep continuation.
So low sweep continuation.
Low sweep.
Low continuation.
If I fail.
This is a 33% win rate.
It returned 15%.
But what I know for sure is that if I now go in here and I go flag for review.
Yes.
And I put it in here.
Here's what I can see.
I can see that these trades, which is one specific principle that I have.
There are some trades that I probably should avoid.
Now, although this has a 20% win rate and is profitable.
It's probably not great that I trade this, this setup.
There aren't a lot of trades, so it doesn't occur frequently.
But with a, with such a low win rate.
The reality is, even if it is profitable, the likelihood that you're going to
get a profitable trade at a certain period of time is.
It is too far in between.
Because I want setups that are quite frequent that I can play with.
So I would rather not take this.
Right.
And lose that it's 1.1% is what it returns.
So it's basically a waste of time taking those trades.
That's how I read it.
So, yeah.
There's like one winner.
One winner for losers one break even.
So I know, for example, there's something in there that I want to remove.
And it's about refinement as well, because the more you have to do, the more
likely error is to occur.
So again, this video is really mainly purpose, mainly purpose.
Let's have a quick look points of interest, all points of interest are
profitable.
But you can start into relating them.
For example, what happens if I take this set up with this point of interest.
And maybe what you find is though, even though some of them are profitable,
return 1%, it returned 3%, but the win rate was super low.
Maybe you don't want to even bother taking those types of trades purely out of
the basis of, you know, if you're, if you've got a proper count, for example,
you know, your, your really performance is based off kind of month to month or
by weekly.
And so do you want to be spending your time taking trades that, that I've got,
like a 20% win rate and you maybe hit one here and there.
Not really.
It's my personal opinion, especially with like a 20% win rate and your average
ratio would like one to five.
It's basically break even because there's no point.
And the reality is is, even though it's basically break even, you're trading a
proper count.
So the reality is, there is a very high likelihood that that trade is going to
be at a loss.
And because it's not something that occurs every single day, if it occurs every
single day and it has like a 20%, it's profitable, then you trade it.
Or when it occurs so, you know, infrequently, if that's even a word, then there
's no point because the reality is when you take that trade, it's probably going
to be a loss.
And so you're better off just focusing on the high probability set ups.
Right.
It's about how you read into your data.
Every single structure flow is profitable.
Every trend phase is profitable.
High premium discount.
They're both profitable, but it's more profitable in premium.
But again, that doesn't mean that, for example, if I removed, if I didn't take,
which is, I did at one point, I'm not going to take any trades that aren't
premium and discount.
Okay, great. You increase your win rate, but you also just missed out on 70%,
77% profit.
So, well done, like you increase your win rate, but that doesn't mean you're
going to make more money.
News gain every fragment of news is profitable.
Execution window. Every execution window is going to be profitable. Our most
profitable execution window, you can see it's pretty evenly correlated between
every hour.
Right. There's no drastic. The highest is 40%, the lowest is 20%, everything
else is in the middle.
So there's nothing to do there and then flag for review, which is just trades
that I want to look at and see if I can understand what's going on in there.
So you can see every setup is profitable pretty much by this one.
The low reversal return 10%, but has a 40% win rate, just not so frequently
traded, which is fine.
So what I really want to obviously look at is the trades that are the most
frequent.
But the reality is, is I want to take every trade that means that criteria.
I want to take every trade that's in that playbook. However, maybe on certain
trades, I actually risk more because that's what's going on.
At the end of the year when that P&L comes in, that one principle alone could
be worth a fortune, just doubling up on my A+ subs.
Right. Having that, I could double my year's P&L comfortably without the excess
risk and stress and drawdown because I understand what my A+ subs are.
So that kind of concludes again, I'm going to go in kind of consult with chat G
PT more and feed it my data, but I don't really think they're going to be much
changes.
To be honest with you, I know that throughout the back test, I said, I think I
can get the win rate higher and so on and so forth, but again, I'm now
finishing it with a 33% win rate.
So the periods with this might have been 25% and I was like, I'm going to get
this win rate higher and yeah, that could have been reality, but 33% win rate
with an average risk reward of 6.2 with a three profit factor.
And I'm winning on 40% of my days. I don't really need to do much of this edge.
This edge is already absolutely solid.
There are a couple of little things I could do which aren't going to make a
huge difference.
I think the biggest takeaway I'll have here is knowing when to double now.
Right, especially when I have buffers and things like that, knowing when, okay,
that's the setup.
This is the setup that I'm most confident in. Maybe I risk a little bit more.
Right.
But yeah, still going to go for the data, but the purpose of this video, again,
obviously I wanted to give you some changes, but honestly, there isn't really
anything to change.
The model is exceptional, but the key takeaway here is for you to be able to do
this yourself.
I've given you a model. The model is exceptionally profitable. There's two and
a half years of data, over 200 trades.
It's a large number of sample size.
Now, the main purpose is, you know, great, you've got a model. Amazing.
That's not going to make you profitable. You need to deal with your psychology.
But the key here is that I've taught you how to fish.
I'm not giving you fish, although I kind of have given you fish in the process,
which is the model.
But they have this old proverb, which is like, you know, give him out of fish,
he'll eat for the day, teach him out of fish, he'll eat for life.
And the purpose of this, to be clear, was not to give you fish, not to give you
a model, not to prove to you that it works.
I don't need to do that.
The purpose of this is to show you how to build an edge, how to collect data,
how to read data, how to make changes.
Right? Because the reality is, this is a model that I've been working on for
five years, pretty much.
I've refined it over the years. So I already know that it's 80% optimized,
which is what I've already said, you know, the 80/20 rule.
I already know that it's 80% optimized.
So this is more about, you know, there may become a time where you want to
build your own edge, or you've seen some things, you want to build an edge.
And when you're building an edge from scratch, for example, you're going to
need huge changes.
You're going to see your data and you're like, whoa, that set up really doesn't
work.
Let me remove that, right? You're going to see actual real discrepancies.
This is an edge that I've been working on for five years. So of course, there's
not that many inefficiencies.
It's kind of expected. I still think there's a couple, but again, it's also
about leverage of time.
You're going to spend your time trying to get very small minor inefficiencies
when you could spend the exact same time doing something with a far higher
output, like building a new edge or doing something else, right?
For example, I could spend my time trying to refine this edge and craft it more
and more blah, blah, blah.
Or I could build a world-class product like what I'm doing right now. This is
part of a world-class product that I'm building, that enables me to monetize
this edge and my knowledge even further, right?
That's a higher leverage plate than just trying to refine this inefficiency.
Again, that's just my two cents. That's how I see the world.
But yeah, hopefully you took a lot of value.
Really, really enjoyed creating this.
This is by far the most valuable program that I've ever built.
And I'm pretty sure you probably said a similar thing you would have ever seen
a program with this level of detail at it before.
I never have.
I wish I did when I was in the beginning. That's why I built this, because it's
everything that I wish I had to start off.
I would have drastically decreased my time to success, even though it was
pretty fast anyway.
But yeah, I hope you guys enjoyed.
Thank you for being here, and I'll see you in the next one.